SUDS NARASIMHAN: Hello, my
name is Suds Narasimhan.
I'm a product manager in Google
Cloud for Cloud AI Notebooks.
Today, I'm going to walk you
through an overview of Cloud AI
Notebooks our managed
JupyterLab notebook
service for enterprises
on Google Cloud.
Today, we'll explore how
Cloud AI Notebooks can
help you explore data quickly
and develop an AI-enabled model
and deploy it into production.
Artificial intelligence
and machine learning
are one of the most--
are one of the key
disruptive technologies
that enterprises have
encountered in the last four
or five years.
And AI and ML will continue
to disrupt enterprises going
forward for the next 10 years.
The key to unlocking value
with artificial intelligence
starts with a model.
And the simplest way to develop
a model is to use notebooks
and, within notebooks, to
use open-source frameworks
to develop AI models.
TensorFlow, PyTorch, and
many other OSS distributions
exist today that can help
you quickly develop a model
and gain insights.
As, a data point, today,
more than 8 million Jupyter
notebooks run on GitHub.
And this notebook count only
is going to continue to grow.
Google has been in the
forefront of bringing notebooks
to different segments of
customers over the past decade.
Kaggle, for example, is targeted
at enthusiasts and people
who are learning to
be data scientists.
Colab is targeted at individual
researchers and students.
And it provides a
collaborative environment
for developing data
science algorithms.
AI Platform Notebooks are
targeted towards enterprises.
This means that AI
Platform Notebooks
come with security built
in, which enterprises really
care about.
Today, we're going to spend some
time looking at AI Platforms
and how it can speed up
your model development.
So, as we noted,
enterprises want
insights in days, not weeks.
This means that
data scientists want
to focus on the difficult
job of model development
and not, essentially,
the peripheral task that
goes around running a
notebook or the infrastructure
associated with a notebook.
Enterprises encounter
several challenges
in running notebooks and
open-source frameworks.
The first thing is around
managing open-source frameworks
and making these--
making the operating
systems, the frameworks,
and the dependencies
work correctly.
Hosting notebooks
and maintaining them
on top of these frameworks
is an additional pain point.
Customers also want to
make sure that the access
to the data that
data scientists use
and the models developed
from the notebook themselves
are secure, and
they're only accessible
by the right personnel.
Since AI and ML
involves accessing data
across the enterprise
landscape, it
is important for
a notebook service
to connect with all of
the data sources that
reside within an
enterprise's data estate.
Our AI Platform Notebook
service solves these problems
by providing three key features.
We completely manage
the installation
of the Jupyter
notebook environment,
along with all the open-source
frameworks and dependencies.
So you don't have to manage
any of that lifecycle.
Our notebooks also ship
with security features
like VPC-SC, CMEK, and other GCP
horizontal features built in.
And Cloud AI Notebooks is also
integrated with several data
services like
BigQuery and Dataproc
that we'll dive
into a little later.
Notebooks are really
easy to get started.
All you have to do is
go to the GCP console,
find Notebooks under the
AI Platform Notebook,
create a new instance
with the required
deep-learning framework
and the type of VM
that you want to
run the notebook on.
So what makes Cloud AI Notebooks
a fully managed experience?
What we do, as part
of Cloud AI Notebooks,
is to pre-install all the
client libraries and all
the environments.
We support popular
open-source environments
like TensorFlow, PyTorch,
and mathematical libraries
like NumPy and SciPy.
To plot, we also provide
open-source tools
like Matplotlib built right
into our deep-learning VM.
On top of these
deep-learning VMs,
our notebooks run, and
they take advantage
of these deep-learning
libraries.
Customers can
configure the notebooks
through the Cloud console.
However, they can
also get a link
to access the Jupyter
notebook using a proxy outside
of the GCP console.
Cloud AI Notebooks
are designed to work
with different kinds of
compute instances within GCP.
Cloud AI Notebooks can run with
DLVMs, as we just spoke about.
These are GCE instances
that come pre-installed
with deep-learning frameworks.
Cloud AI Notebooks can also
work with Dataproc clusters
and Dataflow.
Cloud AI Platforms also
work with custom containers.
So, if you have a specific
deep-learning library
that you want to run within
the custom container,
you can do so and
install a notebook
on top of these containers.
We will talk a little bit more
about our Dataproc integration
in the slides that follow.
Cloud AI Platform also works
with data sources within a GCP
like BigQuery.
So you'll be able to query data
that's stored within BigQuery
and use that data to
train your models.
Let's take a look at how
AI Platform Notebooks
are architected.
are designed
to work with a variety
of compute instances.
We just talked about how it
works with deep-learning VMs,
which are GCE container--
GCE instances with
pre-installed deep-learning
frameworks within the VM.
AI Platform Notebooks also
work with Dataproc clusters
and Dataflow.
AI Platform Notebooks also
work with custom containers,
which means that, if you have a
special deep-learning framework
that you want to run, you can
create a custom container out
of it and have AI
Platform Notebooks work
with those containers.
AI Platform Notebooks work
with a variety of data sources
within GCP.
For example, you can
query data from BigQuery,
use that data as the
basis to train your model.
AI Platform Notebooks
are also well
integrated with Git repositories
and other source control
systems.
So it's easy to push and pull
code into these repositories.
So why would you want to
use AI Platform Notebooks?
AI Platform Notebooks
makes it really easy
to get started with
your model development.
Since you don't have
to deal with installing
these deep-learning frameworks
or setting up the notebook
environment, you can get
started very, very quickly.
In addition, since
AI Platform Notebooks
is a managed JupyterLab
service, the environment
around code development is very
familiar for data scientists.
AI Platform Notebooks enable
you to scale and control costs
effectively.
So you could start with
a very small instance
for model development.
And, as you ramp
up your training,
you could move to a bigger VM.
Or, better yet, you could use
a GPU or much powerful machines
in order to train your models.
AI Platform Notebooks comes
with security built in.
So, as we talked about VPC-SC,
IAM controls, as well as
CMEK controls are built right
into AI Platform Notebooks.
AI Platform Notebooks are also
integrated with other services
within GCP.
So it plays within an
ecosystem of analytic tools,
as well as our AI Platform.
So AI Platform
makes it really easy
to build, train, and
deploy these models.
Let's talk about
some recent updates
that we have made to
our notebook service
in the last six months.
We recently announced an
integration with Kaggle.
Kaggle, as you may
know, is a community
of 5 million data scientists
who write and share code.
With this integration between
Kaggle and AI Platform
Notebooks, customers
have access to GCP's
limitless and customizable
compute environment
that allows users to scale
up their work very easily.
We've already seen thousands
of customers from Kaggle
go to Cloud AI Notebooks
using this integration,
and we expect these numbers to
grow in the next few months.
One of the recent
integrations we announced
was with Dataproc through the
smart analytics framework.
The smart analytics
framework brings together
Apache Beam and
Dataproc together
with AI Platform Notebooks.
Customers typically need to
analyze petabytes of data
before starting to
work on a model.
With this built-in
integration with Spark,
analytics and deep learning
can be authored from one place.
The Dataproc Hub brings
enterprise controls
to Spark clusters based
on notebook interfaces.
If you want to learn further
about Apache Beam notebooks,
there's a fantastic
tutorial when you launch--
when you launch a notebook
using smart analytics framework
and when you choose Apache Beam.
As you can see, the
experience to using
smart analytics framework is
super easy to get started.
All you would have to do is pick
the smart analytics frameworks
choice and either pick Apache
Beam or Dataproc distributions,
instead of a TensorFlow
or a PyTorch distribution,
as you would for a
deep-learning environment.
So the goal of
Cloud AI Notebooks
is to help you develop models
quickly and allow you to easily
scale and streamline that
model within your production
workflows.
Let's take a quick look
at some of the examples
around how you can
go about doing that.
Cloud AI Notebooks provides a
means to plug into your data
pipelines that enables
feature engineering
as well as data
labeling very easily.
Cloud AI Notebooks helps you
model your data efficiently
with what-if analysis and, also,
embedded AutoML capabilities.
You can evaluate
your model quickly
with feature attributions,
what-if analysis,
and continuous evaluations.
We've also built in algorithms
like optimization, AutoML,
and NAS right into
Cloud AI Notebooks
that makes model developments
simple and faster.
On top of this,
Cloud AI Notebooks
runs on a hybrid platform and
a multi-cloud platform that
also has access to some of
the most powerful compute you
will find anywhere in the
world, for example, TPUs.
Cloud AI Notebooks makes it easy
for you to scale and streamline
your model
development with ease.
Cloud AI Notebooks works in
an ecosystem of data services
and AI services.
Cloud AI Notebooks can
be easily integrated
into your data pipeline.
So, if you ingest
data using Data Fusion
or transform data using Dataproc
and put it into BigQuery,
you can easily access
that data, label the data,
and use that data for training.
As previously mentioned,
Notebooks also
makes it easy to build,
develop, and train
a model with built-in tools such
as prebuilt algorithms, AutoML,
and access to our
training service.
Cloud AI Notebooks also makes
it easy to deploy these models
by verifying your
model performance using
explainable AI, as well as
directly deploying the model
into our prediction service.
Our prediction
service also ships
with a continuous
evaluation feature
that helps you to monitor the
model once it's in production.
All these components
are built with access
to a pipeline that
makes it easier
to containerize and monitor
the entire workflow end to end.
One such tool that's built
into AI Platform Notebooks
is Explainable AI.
Explainable AI is
a set of libraries
that help you figure
out why your model made
a particular prediction.
For example, on the right, you
can see a color-coded heat map
of what the most important
features were in making
a particular prediction.
Explainable AI can be useful
tabular, image, text TensorFlow
models.
Explainable AI also ships
with a built-in What-If Tool.
[INAUDIBLE] What-If Tool,
you could change the values
for attributes that you're
building with a model
and figure out how much
it impacts the prediction
of that particular model.
Explainable AI
libraries are already
available in some of our
deep-learning distributions
today.
And they will be available
in more in the coming weeks.
Of course, AI Platform
Notebooks runs
in an AI-optimized
infrastructure within GCP.
For example, our v3 TPU pods
provide 84% faster performance
in both object detection
and machine translation
compared to on-prem
infrastructure.
This AI-optimized
infrastructure is
only available on GCP
among public clouds.
And they clearly outperform
on-prem systems in MLPerf.
Looking ahead at our roadmap
extending beyond 2020,
it's worth looking back
on where we came from.
We launched AI Platform
Notebooks in beta
in April 2019.
And, since the time
that we have launched,
we've seen tremendous
interest among enterprises
for developing models
using Cloud AI Notebooks.
We've seen significant
user growth and adoption
in the last year that
helped us successfully
GA the product in March 2020.
Beyond 2020, we hope
to build in features
around machine learning
operations, lineage tracking,
collaboration, and integration
across our entire analytics
estate.
As next steps, we invite you
to read our Notebooks Manifesto
blog that's available on
the Google Cloud blog site,
as well as get started with
Cloud AI Notebooks using
a five-minute tutorial that's
available on our product page.
You can also learn
about all the features
in in-depth documentation on
the product page on Google Cloud
Platform.
Thank you for joining us today.
I hope you enjoyed
this presentation
and you have a good
rest of the day
and you enjoy our other
Next '20 presentations.